[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انها الساعه ستون
برنامج اخباري خاص ومتنوع وبقاع سريع
ومختلف جدا نحلل الاحداث بابعادها وبعمق
وبين العاجل والمهم نضع امامكم الاهم
والصوره الكامله البدايه من العناوين جيش
اسرائيل مهدد احتجاج والاحتياط يتسع تصعيد
ضد خطط نتنياهو قد يتحول لعصيان شامل
انتخابات رئاسيه على انقاذ الزلزال تركيا
المدمر معارضه كادت ان تهتز فاتفقت هل على
اردوغان القلق وفي ملفات الساعه ستون سجال
يتجدد بين القاهره واديس ابابا بشان سد
النهضه فوضاه بلا افق واستعدادات لملئ
جديد
الفيدرالي الامريكيه يرفع الفائده فيدفع
العالم الثمن اما الداخل سيعيش متلازمه
البطاله والتضخم
[موسيقى]
تسميها الحكومه اصلاحا وتصفها المعارضه
بالانقلاب النتيجه انسداد يضع واقعه
اسرائيل على المحك ما بداه نتنياهو مع
القضاء والمحكمه العليا وبخطوات نحو تشريع
التغييرات القانونيه ينظر اليها على انها
خطه محكمه وضعها لانقاذ نفسه من ملفات
الفساد ومنح الشرعيه لوزراء حكومته
المدننه بتهم جنائيه الاف الاسرائيليين
سدوا مداخل مطار بنغوريون في تل ابيب
تتصاعد الاحتجاجات الشعبيه ضد حكومه اقصى
اليمين والاحتجاجات اجبرت على استقلال
مروحيه الى مطار بن غوريان بعد قطع
المتظاهرين الطريق عليه في حادثه عزل على
اثرها قائد الشرطه الاسرائيليه ولم يكن
المطار بوابه سفر فقط لرئيس الوزراء
الاسرائيلي الى ايطاليا ما لقاء
الزانيه بوزير الدفاع الامريكي
واوضع الشارع او المعارضه التي تريد اسقاط
الحكومه بحسبنا المياه
بنامك الامر يعتمد على النظر الى الامور
بعمق مهما كانت الاختلافات بيننا يجب
علينا البقاء متحدين في مواجهه اولئك
الذين يسعون لقتلنا كان هذا هو الحال طوال
حروب اسرائيل بغض النظر عن الصراعات
والخلافه بيننا رفض هذه الحقيقه يهدد هذا
الاساس الوجوديه لدولتنا
الاحتجاجات التي لم تخلو من اعتقالات
ومواجهه مع الشرطه بعد تخليها عن
استراتيجيه ضبط النفس الاسبوع الماضي تاخذ
الان منعطفا جديدا لاسيما مع الدعوه الى
عصيان الاوامر العسكريه بين ضباط وجنود من
الجيش الاسرائيلي معظمهم من الاستخبارات
العسكريه وسلاح الجو وقوات النخبه
والمدفعيه دقه نقوص الخطر الحقيقي بعد ان
اعلن هؤلاء عزمهم عدم المشاركه في تدريبات
كانت مقرره لهم سبعه وثلاثون طيارا
احتياطيا اسرائيليا من اصل اربعين يعتزمون
عدم الحضور لتدريبات مقرره الاربعاء
المقبل والقلق يتصاعد من ظاهره رفض الخدمه
العسكريه التي تطورت وبلغت ابعاد مطلقه
بحسب رئيس الاركان هيرسي هوليدي وهو الذي
حذر نتنياهو من ان هذا العصيان سيضر
بقدرات الجيش العمليه وتسرب
المكالمه بينهما كان مطلقا ايضا وزير
الامن الاسرائيلي يعاف جلند حليفنا
نتنياهو دعا الى حل الازمه ببدء مفاوضات
بين معسكر المعارضه والائتلاف حول القانون
المثير للجدل الذي يسعى نتنياهو الى
تمريره وفجر التظاهرات في الشارع منذ
مطلعي يناير
[موسيقى]
اذا انقسامات اسرائيليه قد تصل الى نقطه
لا عوده بحسب الرئيس الاسرائيلي اسحاق
هرتسوغ الذي كان يتوسط بين جانبي الازمه
جميع الاوساط السياسيه والعسكريه باتت
تستشعر خطر الانهيار الكامل بعد ان وصل
لاحتقان الى المؤسسات العسكريه فالطيرون
الممتنعون عن الخدمه هم جزء من السربه 69
المسمى صرب المطرقه ويتكون من مقاتلات اف
15 المخصصه لمهاجمه اهداف بعيده والمكون
ايضا من اربعين طيارا ومقره في قاعده
حتسريم الجويه في صحراء النقب غربي مدينه
بيرس سبع اذا استمر هؤلاء على موقفهم لم
يبقى احد ليطير في مهمات وهو اختصار عبري
لحمله بين الحروب اي اوقات الح غير
الرسميه ضد اهداف في سوريا او بعض المواقع
النوويه الايرانيه بحسب موقع ول العبري
وهذا الامتناع هو اتساع مقلق لما بداه
مئات ضباط الاحتياط في وحده الاستخبارات
العسكريه 8,200 بقرارهم في الثامن
والعشرين من فبراير
[موسيقى]
ستحول اسرائيل الى دوله منبوذه بحسبها
خاصه وانه هو من تسبب بانتفاضه مايو 2021
التي طالت مدن الخط الاخضر ونتجت عنها
مواجهات في مدن وبلدات عده اذا للمزيد
ينضم الينا من تل ابيب المستشار السابق
بوزاره الامن الاسرائيلي ابيتار اهلا بك
اذا الى اي مدى لو بدانا من هذه
الاضطرابات في الداخل الاسرائيلي الى اي
مدى يمكن لهذا العصيان ان يمتد خاصه بعد
ان وصل الى المؤسسات العسكريه نتحدث الان
عن السرب 69 وايضا عن الاستخبارات
العسكريه
اكيد في ازمه في ازمه
ميكا في داخل اسرائيل داخل المجتمع وبين
المؤسسات واحزاب السياسيه
و الاحتجاج نحن شايفين انه في كمان
من
الزبات الاختياطي يجوز منهم من سلاح القاو
يجوز منهم من المشاه ومن الوحدات الخاصه
بس حبيت اوضح انه غلبياتهم هم فوق من من
عمر الخدمه معناته انه
غلبياتهم اكثر من
هم اكيد نوعيه الناس بس نحن لازم نذكر انه
لحد هلا
ولا واحد هرب من الخدمه من الخدمه
الاختيار
لماذا يخاف هؤلاء من هذه الخطه
داخل المجتمع الاسرائيلي من الازمه
الداخلي من الخلافات من النكاشات من
حجم الاحتجاج وحجم المعارضه ضد الحكومه
الاسرائيليه اكيد نحن موجودين في ازمه
قانونيه في ازمه دستوريه
لحد هلا ما في اي
خلينا نقول نكاش حقيقي على وصول الى تسويه
او الى
نسط الى وصول الموصوله
اظن لما نحكي على زبات من من الجيش هم مش
مطلوبين لوحدات
بشكل دائم نحن نحكي على ذباب جزء منهم
طيارين يجوز جوز منهم
من
القوات الجو
متطوعين معناته انه ما له ايجابيات حسب
القانون
لخدمه حسب
بشكل يومي او اسبوعي المملكه لكن يعني
امتناهم عن الخدمه يعكس موقفا من هذا
القرار بالتالي ما سر هذا الاصرار الذي
نتنياه هناك ضغوط الداخليه احتجاجات
مستمره منذ اكثر من شهرين هناك ايضا ضغوط
ومطالبات دوليه الولايات المتحده طلبته
بالتنازل عن هذه الخطه التراجع عنها يعني
ما سر هذا الاصرار حتى الان
اذا حاول اصور الصوره بشكل دقيق
الضغوطات على نتانيان لسه نحن مو شايفين
انه في
استعدادات داخل الحكومه الاسرائيليه من
تنيول لحد وزير العدل لوصول الى تصويع لحد
هلا نحن شايفين انه في استمرار بنسبه لا
اجراءات القانونيه واجراءات القدام من
ناحيه الحكومه
ولسه ما في اي استراحه او اي
لسه ما طولت المفاوضات بين الجانبين لسه
فتحوها
بس في تهديدات واحتجاجات قويه
جدا
بحجم كبير
جايين من المج تمع من تحت للفوق من قوات
نوعيه زي زي ذبات زي
شو زي شركات اقتصاديه وهو الى اخرين
وكمان مين من الخارج
لسه نحن سمعنا انه في ضغوطات كمان من
البيت الابيض بس ما حجم
الضغوطات والاحتجاج من بيت الابيض لسه ما
وصل في نهايه المطاف الا قوى تنفيذيه من
ناحيه
الضغط على لوقف
الاجراءات القانونيه
عن اي عن اي سيناريوهات الان نتحدث
نحن هلا شايفين انه اديني اول سيناريو هو
وصول الى ازمه
كانونيه او ازمه دستوريه داخل اسرائيل
معناته انه الحكومه الاسرائيليه تمشي
بتنفيذ الاجراءات القانونيه
خلال الاسبوعين ثلاثه الجايه معناته وصول
الى قتل نهايه من ناحيه البرنامج
وسياستهم
ومن
وكمان اذا ينفذوا كل الاجراءات هاي معناته
المحاكم والمحكمه العليا ما يقبل
القوانين معناته يكون شكوى من المؤسسات
المختلفه داخل اسرائيل شكوى
لمحكمه العليا من اجل رفض
وعدم
عدم الموافقه لاجراءات القان تبع الحكومه
وهي نقطه هزم الدستوريه
ان احنا رايحين الى هذه النكته هيك سبيل
واحد سبيل الثاني
وهل السيناريو هو
وصول الى نقطه التسويه تسويه معناته
تنازل معين صغير من ناحيه الحكومه بالنسبه
للتنفيذ
الاجراءات القانونيه وكمان من ناحيه
المعارضه
من ناحيه المؤسسات اللي
الاحتجاج من ناحيتهم كمان يكون تنازل معين
على
مصالحهم والطالباتهم بالنسبه
لاجراءات هاي نص الطريق اذا نحن رايحين لا
ازمه دستوريه بين المؤسسات بين السلطه
التنفيذيه وسلطه المحاكم
السيناريو هاي هو الوجه نعم اشكرك جزيل
الشكر انتهى وقت هذه المقابله كنت معنا من
تل ابيب المستشار السبت بوزاره الامن
الاسرائيليه
هل عوده رئيسه حزب الجيد دائبه الصدعه
داخل تحالف المعارضه التركيه في الساعه
بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
هنا خطايا جنوب شرق تركيا وتحديدا مجمع
النهضه السكني الفاخر او ما تبقى منه بعد
الزلزال هناك كانت الحياه احلام وهموم
وتفاصيل عديده اما الان لم يتبقى سوى
انقاذ والبومه
بعد شهر من الزلزال او على بعد شهرين من
الانتخابات الاستحقاق المصيريه التاريخيه
في تركيا
كمال كليجدار اوغلو زعيم حزبي الشعب
الجمهوري مرشح التحالف
المعارضه المشترك للانتخابات الرئاسيه هذا
التوافق وصف بالخطوه التاريخيه المرشح
المنافس الجمهوريه قدمه زعيم حزب السعاده
الاسلاميه كتفا بكتف من مع رفاق السابقين
طيور
[موسيقى]
بشكره هذا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الاسلام
في الاعلانيه ايضا ظهرت اكشنار رئيسه حزب
الجيده ضلع الطاوله السداسيه الذي كاد ان
يفكك تحالف المعارضه لكن هل عوده اكشنار
الرقبه الصدعه داخل تحالف المعارضه ربما
وربما عمقها لكن لا التحالف ولا اكشنار
يمكنهما ان يتراجع خطوه لماذا الكلفه
السياسيه عاليه قد تقضي على مستقبلها
السياسي وقد تهدم تهدي الخصم اللدود
الرئيس اردوغان وحزبه الح ما يريده تفتيت
جبهه المعارضه
[موسيقى]
جدا
زلزال سياسي ضرب جبهه المعارضه لكنها خرجت
بمرشحها الرئاسي حزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم امام الصيغه ليست سهله جلسوا
وتحدثوا وتفرقوا هكذا تحكم اردوغان على
الطاوله السداسيه لكن تحالف المعارضه
اليوم ليس كذلك ياتي الزلزال فيتحول الى
ارضيه خصبه لمهاجمه الحكومه والحزب الحاكم
توضيف الكارثه سياسيا
الاحزاب المعارضه وزعيمها زعيم حزب الشعب
الجمهوري السيد كمال كليتجار اوغلو يقومون
بتحريض الشعب للوقوف ضدنا ووضعوا عراقيل
امام عجله النمو والتحول المدني في الماضي
والان يكررون نفس توجهاتهم
اختبارا حاسم يحتاج الرئيس الى تجاوز
عقبات كبيره الازمه الاقتصاديه
وكارثه الزلزال
بسبب يعتمد
لكن ماذا في اجابه المعارضه ايضا انتقاد
لنهج اردوغان الاقتصادي محاولات كبح
التضخم برفع للفوائد والنتيجه معدل تضخم
سنوي بلغ خمسه
فحين اتحدت المعارضه عام 2019 في
الانتخابات البلديه فازت في اهم معاقله
اسطنبول وانقره
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
الجميع منشغل بهمومه الان بسبب الزلزال
الوقت حاليا ليس وقت الانتخابات الان
الكثير من الاحزاب السياسيه منشغله في
هموم الانتخابات
الفتره هي فتره صعبه حدث زلزال وتاثر به
13 مليون شخص وهناك الكثير من المفقودين
والكثير من الناس لم يتبقى لهم عناوين
برايي يجب ان تقام الانتخابات في وقتها
لكي نتخلص من اردوغان انا لا اريد هذا
الشخص
بالطبع تاثر الوضع بالزلزال وبرايي يجب
عدم اجراء الانتخابات ويجب ان تتاخر قليلا
لانه لدينا الكثير من الضحايا والخسائر
الماديه
[موسيقى]
انها المياه هو الصراع على مواردها وبحاله
سد النهضه من صدودها الى مصبها نزاعات
المياه اصبحت سمه القرن الحالي الملء
الرابع لسد النهضه بات وشيكا في اثيوبيا
مصر غير راضيه وهي التي لوحت اكثر من مره
باكثر من خيار تحاول القاهره مجددا اللجوء
الى مجلس الامن الذي ناء بنفسه سابقا
واحال الازمه الى الوساطه الافريقيه التي
لم تفلح في دفع اثيوبيا الى تغيير موقفها
اليوم اثيوبيا ورغم الرفض المصري
والسوداني ماضيه في تعبئه تضمن الملا
الرابع وتعرب عن استيائها من قرار جامعه
الدول العربيه بادراج ملف سد النهضه
كابندن دائن في مجلس الجامعه وزير
الخارجيه المصري سامح شكري دعاها بدوره
للتحلي بالمسؤوليه مع التجديد على ان
بلاده ستضمن حقوقها امام الامر الواقع
واعتباري اثيوبيا قرارات مجلس الامن غير
ملزمه وصلت ازمه السد الى سد بالاساس مصر
والسودان
تواجهتها سابقا الى مجلس الامن وفق البند
السادس صلاحيات المجلس وفق هذا البند هي
تقديم توصيات للاطراف المتنازعه للعوده
الى طويله الحوار بالنسبه لاثيوبيا السد
اساسي لتنميه اقتصاديه فهي تريد تشغيل 16
توربينا لتوفير الطاقه ل 60% من
الاثيوبيين معادله مقلقه بالنسبه لمصر
فكميه المياه التي تصلها ستتناقص وما تبعت
ذلك
حصه مصر من النيل تبلغ 55 مليار متر مكعب
سنويا الملا الرابع اذا تم بشكل كامل فهو
يستهدف الوصول بحجم المياه التي سيتم
تخزينها الى 40 مليار متر مكعب لو خسرت
مصر 5 مليارات متر مكعب من المياه مثلا
فسيؤدي ذلك الى خساره مليون فدان من
ثمانيه ملايين اجمالي الاراضي الزراعيه
بحسب دراسه من جامعه كاليفورنيا وهنا
انعكاس كبير للموقف المصري وواقع التهديد
الغذائي التي تنطلق منها الازمه ووفقا
للدراسه نفس الدراسه فانه في اسوا
السيناريوهات السيناريوه السنوات الثلاث
للملء سيفقد ستفقد قرابه اربعه ملايين
و750,000 عامل بالزراعه في مصر مصدر دخلهم
من اصل 5 ملايين ونصف المليون عامل اما
السودان اللاعب الثاني في الازمه وهو دوله
مصب حصته المائيه 18 مليار متر مكعب من
نهر النيل السودان واذا حرمه الملء الرابع
من خمسه مليارات متر مكعب متوقعه هذا
العام فهو على عكس مصر التي تمتلك السد
العالي ما يجعل خساره مصر من المياه خساره
من فائض فان اكبر سدود السودان الرصيرس لا
تتجاوز سعته التخزينيه 10% من سعه سد
النهضه السدود الصغيره تضع السودان في وضع
حرج في اي موسم جفاف سابق الاهم في هذه
المشكله ما سيحدث بعد ذلك السد سيتحول الى
قنبله مائيه قد تفقد مصر والسودان الخيار
العسكري وهذا لنلقي نظره اقرب الى الخريطه
لنفهم لماذا
كميه المياه خلف السد منذ انتهاء الملا
الثاني اي قبل عام ونصف العام من الان
تهدد بجرف مدن مصريه وسودانيه الى البحر
المتوسط ان حدث طوفان السد يواجه بالاساس
خطر الانهيار بنسبه خمسين في المئه
والاسباب عده اولا طبيعه المنطقه التي
تحتوي على فوالق ارضيه ليست مناسبه بالطبع
لبناء السدود موقعه في منطقه جبليه في بني
شنغول واحتماليه انحدار صخور قابله
للتفتيت مع الطبيعه المطريه المسببه
للسيول ونذكر مشاهدينا خطر الانهيار بدا
منذ ان وضعت اديس ابابا حجر الاساس لهذا
السد سد النهضه في 2011 وذلك بسبب معامل
الامان المنخفض في السد والذي اثار قلق
واشنطن والبنك الدولي منذ ذلك الحين واكدت
اللجنه الدوليه اثناء معاينه السد في 2011
ان وضعه مرعب وم خيف فماذا عن وضعه الان
[موسيقى]
بالمناسبه اثيوبيا ترفض حتى اليوم الكشف
عنا معامل امان السد وهذا مثل احدى النقاط
الخلافيه مع مصر والسودان انهيار السد ان
وقع ستبدو موجات تسونامي مجرده العاب
مائيه سيسبب الانهيار مشاهدينا موجه ضخمه
بعرض 150 كيلو مترا وبارتفاع 25 مترا تجرف
مدنا باكملها في السودان تقضي على 20
مليون شخص اضافه الى ملايين اخرين في مصر
ستصلهم الموجه بعد 17 يوما واسد النهضه
للعلم احد اكبر عشره سدودا في العالم
[موسيقى]
متعدد الابعاد في لبنان ومحافظات الشمال
المتضرر الاكبر في الساعه بعد دقيقه
[موسيقى]
كما او الذهب الاصفر كما يلقبه الباعه في
احد اكبر اسواق مدينه حماه السوريه يشكل
هذا النوع من الفطر مصدر رزقا لكثير من
السوريين الذين يخاطرون بارواحهم من جمعه
من الصحراء غير ابهين بخطر الالغام
المتناثره او من هجمات تنظيم داعش ارقامنا
صادمه كشفها المرصد السوري فقد احصى مقتل
130 شخصا في الباديه السوريه خلال جمعهم
للكماء معظمهم بنيران 11
التعليم ام الخبز الصحه ام الملبس كثيرا
من هذه الخيارات سقطت من حسابات
اللبنانيين في ظل فقر يتوحش على طول
البلاد وعرضها بعد بعض الحقوق الادميه
باتت من الكماليات في لبنان فالتعليم
بالنسبه لحالات اصبحت طرفا بمعنى ان الحق
في الغذاء يتعرض لتهديد شديد في المجتمع
في تقرير سابق لها وجدت ان انعدام الامن
الغذائي قد وصل الى مستويات تنذر بالخطر
لكن الى اي حد الى حد ان تعيش عائلات
الجوع بما فيها الاطفال كما تقول المنظمه
فهل فعلا وصل الامر الى هذا الحد نعم
واسوا من ذلك
يعني بحسب الطبخه بروح وبجيب السوق 100
مره قدام معي هالقد هاي قديه بتكلف هاي
قديه بتكلف حتى اقدر اجيبها
ما عاد فيني كافيه عند الحكيم ما بيرحموا
[موسيقى]
بنادول
صغير في بركان جوا معشعش جوا يعني بس ناطر
بس هيك نتفه صغيره
الان ايضا من وزاره الشؤون الاجتماعيه
تقول انها تلقت 500 الف طلب من اسر
لبنانيه اعلنت فقرها صنف منها 300 الف الف
ضمن الاسر الاكثر فقرا في البلاد
اللبنانيون اليوم يمزقهم الفقر هناك
مليونا ونصف المليون لبناني تحتها خط
الفقر ومليونين ونصف المليون فوقه وفقا
لدراسه للامم المتحده الوضع اذا مازوم
وكارثي للغايه
تغيرت وغيرت وبدلت في طبقات المجتمع
اللبناني الطبقه الوسطى تراجعت من سبعين
الى اربعين في المئه نسبته طبقه فوق خط
الفقر بلغت 30 في المئه ومن هم تحت خط
الفقره ف 25% تبقى طبقه الاثرياء يشكلون
5% من لبنان هل سيشهد لبنان تغيرا اخر في
هذه الطبقات الاجابه نعم فالنسبه الفقراء
ارتفعت من 25 الى
55% وهي مرشحه للارتفاع العام الحليبي
بشكل كبير وتشير خريطه توزيع اللبنانيين
واللاجئين الاكثر فقرا او ضعفا كما تصفهم
الامم المتحده يقدرون بمليوني شخص يعيشون
في وضع خطر تعجز الدوله ومؤسساتها عن
تلبيه احتياجاتهم رغم ما تقدمه عبر وزاره
الشؤون الاجتماعيه
حكومه لبنان اصدرت اول مؤشرا متعدد
الابعاد للفقره تتوزع هذه الابعاد على
التعليم والصحه الرفاه المالي والبنيه
التحتيه الاساسيه والمستويات المعيشيه لكن
كيف يعشها اللبنانيون الكهرباء مثلا كبوس
يعيشه اللبنانيون يوميا توفر الحكومه
حاليا الكهرباء فقط لمده تتراوح بين ساعه
وثلاث ساعات في المتوسط بينما يسد الاشخاص
القادرون على دفع تكاليف اضافيه نقصت
تغذيه الكهربائيه بمولدات خاصه ولهذا
تكلفه اضافيه ليس بمقدور الجميع ان
يتحملها تساهم ازمه الكهرباء في تفاقم عدم
المساواه ودفع الناس الى الفقر كيف تكلفه
الكهرباء اثرت على قدره الاسر على دفع
تكاليف الخدمات الاساسيه الاخرى في قطاع
اخر تطال الازمه المستفحله المرضى
فالحكومه خفضت اجمالي انفاقها في القطاع
الصحي بالنسبه 40 بين عامي 2018 و2022 كما
ان هناك نقصا حادا في الادويه اذا رفعت
الحكومه الدعم عن ادويه
والمستوردون عجزون عن استيراد الادويه
بسبب الازمه الماليه يبدو ان لبنان يتجه
نحو سياسه الدوله على امل تحقيق الاستقرار
في الاقتصاد التعامل بالدولار لكن ليس
الكل قادر على الدفع بالدولار معضله اخرى
تعمق الفقر في البلاد نقص العمله في
البنوك والحد من عمليات السحب ضياع مدخرات
الكثير من الناس
لا لا الاسبوع الاول من شهر مارس وفيما
يشير اختصاصي وعلم النفس الا ان الازمات
الاقتصاديه لا يمكن ان تؤدي الى الانتحار
الا انها السبب الاساسيه لتاذن الصحه
النفسيه للبنانيين ومع الانهيار المستمر
لقيمه الرواتب بالليره اللبنانيه غادر عدد
كبير من اللبنانيين الطبقه الوسطى باتجاه
الطبقه الفقيره وبحسب المعايير الدوليه
فان خمسه وثمانين بالمئه من اللبنانيين
يعانون من فقر متعدد الابعاد اما المعايير
المحليه فتشير الى ان خمسه وخمسين بالمئه
منهم غير قادرين حتى على اشباع حاجاتهم
الغذائيه الازمه دخلت تعامها الرابع
ازدادت معها معدلات المطاله والتفكك
الاسري وحالات الانتحار وفقدت القطاعات
التربويه والاستشفائيه صنعتها الطيبه
نحن صايمين
مستشفى الحكومه شفتها حكومه 16 مليون
لبناني و160$ عندي اربع اولاد الله ما
فينا
اذا بدك تبديهم الولد بده 20 دولار ودولار
ما بياخذ لبنان الا دولار منين بده يجيب
له انا طعميهم
[موسيقى]
مره تلو الاخرى يرفع الفيدراليه الامريكيه
اسعار الفائده لمواجهه التضخم داخل
الولايات المتحده لكن النتيجه تكون عكسيه
على بقيه اقتصادات العالم خاصه الناشئه
منها فاسعار الفائده المرتفعه في امريكا
تجذب الاستثمارات العالميه وترفع من قيمه
الدولار العمله الاكثر استخداما في
المعاملات الماليه العالميه وبالتالي
تزداد تكلفه كل شيء تقريبا على الاقتصادات
الناميه من سداد الديون والقرود الى
الواردات تصريحاته رئيس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي المتفائله حول تخفيف التضخم قبل
اسابيع ادت الانتعاش الاسواق وزياده
الانفاق عامل يضاف الانخفاض نسبه البطاله
ليعود شبح رفع الفائده من جديد وايضا عبر
تصريحات جرم باول
تعرف
والى جانب انخفاض البطاله هناك زياده في
الرواتب عوامل تبدو ايجابيه ولكن في معركه
امريكا الحاليه ضد التضخم قد تكون ضاره
اكثر من 340 الف موظف امريكي زادت
مرتباتهم مطلع الشهر الجاري سياده الرواتب
تعني قوه شراء اكثر يعني ارتفاع الطلب
الاستهلاكي وبالتالي التضخم ان تجعل الطلب
[موسيقى]
قلنا من الوقوع في دوامه الاجور والاسعار
حيث تؤدي زياده الاجور الى زياده الاسعار
والتي بدورها تؤدي تؤدي الى زيادات في
الاجور
ازمه التضخم الحاليه في امريكا برامج دعم
مالي ضخمه من الحكومه لمواجهه تداعيات
كورونا الاقتصاديه احدها قدمت تريليون
دولار نقدا للامريكيين تدفقت الاموال
فازداد الطلب على السلع والخدمات لكن
الشركات لم تستطع مواكبه الطلب لاسباب
مختلفه ما بين نقص في اشباه الموصلات
وتوقف حركات الشحن العالمي النتيجه اذا
التضخم امريكي بنسبه 6.4 النسبه تبدو
ضئيله لكن تاثير التضخم على بعض المنتجات
الغذائيه الاساسيه كان هائلا ما ادى لحدوث
زياده سنويه كبيره في تكلفه الغذاء في
المدارس الامريكيه بنسبه تصل الى
254% متى سعر وجبه الغداء في المدارس
الابتدائيه نحو ثلاثه دولارات اسعار تذاكر
الطيران في مطارات امريكا قفزت بنسبه 36%
امرا متوقع بعد ارتفاع تكاليف الوقود الى
جانب نقص العماله وارتفاع الطلب بعد
الخروج من جائحه كورونا اما تذاكر خدمات
النقل العام فارتفعت بنسبه
23.8 في المئه وكل هذا يلمسه الشارع
ساسطون كان هناك وسال
معنى هبه القدسي مديره مكتب صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط من واشنطن اهلا بك اذن السيده هبه
زياده الرواتب وانخفاض البطاله هي عوامل
ايجابيه لكنها تصب في ارتفاع التضخم في
امريكا عن اي مازق اقتصادي نتحدث الان في
الولايات المتحده
نعم هناك مخاوف كبيره من دخول الاقتصاد
الامريكي الى مرحله ركود خاصه ان بنك
الاحتياطي الفيدرالي الامريكي
ما زال يتوقع زياده في رفع اسعار الفائده
اعلى من المتوقع وما زالت الاهداف التي
اعلنها تونسون مستويات التضخم الى اثنين
بالمئه ليست قريبه من التحقق وهذا يضع
تداعيات كثيره على الاقتصاد الامريكي وعلى
المستهلكين بشكل عام وعلى اسعار السلع
الغذائيه وما يتبعها من الرهون العقاريه
وفوائد البنوك على القرود سواء للشركات او
للافراد من ثقه الاقتصادي كبير مع ارتفاع
اسعار الفائده ويعرض الاقتصاد الامريكي
لفشل المصرفي يعد الاحدث منذ الاز
العالميه الماليه في عام 2008
سيده هبه
نعم يلام كثيرا على الفيدرالي الامريكي
انه تاخر في استيعاب التضخم وصفه بانه
عابر وعراضي اكثر من مره الان السؤال هل
سيستطيع ان يذهب بالاقتصاد نحو السيف
لاندينج او يعني الهبوط الناعم الى نسبه
اثنين في المئه النسبه التاريخيه التي يجب
ان تكون عليها
يجب ان يكون عليها التضخم
بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي مع معدلات التضخم
المرتفعه التي وصلت في بعض الاحيان الى
20%
كمعدلات
لاسعار السنه الغذائيه بشكل عام وهناك
يعني قلق من ان
مسعى بنك الاحتياطي الفيدرالي لمكافحه
التضخم من خلال نوع من الزيادات المطرده
في رفع اسعار الفائده ستؤدي الى حاله من
الكاسات وهذا سيؤثر على الاقتصاد الامريكي
خاصه مع ارتفاع
الموازنه العامه وال القروض او يعني حاله
القروض الامريكيه الى اكثر من 30 ترليون
دولار وتازم سياسي ما بين البيت الابيض
[موسيقى]
في الامريكي فيما يتعلق برفع سعر برقب رفع
سقف الديون وهذا يعني اننا على اعتاب
مشاكل اقتصاديه كثيره لم يستطيع
الاتحاد الفيدرالي القيام بدور حاسم في
ضبط السوق بشكل المرجو وهذا يسبب الكثير
من الارتباك والكثير من
القلق داخل الاسواق الماليه نعم شكرا
جزيلا لك كتب ناهبه القدسي مديره مكتب
صحيفه الشرق الاوسط في واشنطن
مستشار رئيس الوزراء اليابانيه في تصريح
صادم سنختفي من الوجود والسبب انخفاض
اعداد المواليد في البلاد لمستوى القياسي
من الان وحتى التعلق بلال انا حنين
الشوليه وهذه الساعه
[موسيقى]